Ian Lick: No actions like stopping music
To be very far, if necessary.
Android has provided many ways
To do this like screen lock controls,
Media controls for notifications, Android ware,
And even "Android Auto", for example.
So how does your audio application work with all this quality?
This is easy with MediaSessionCombat
A single API is available through the Android Help Library
Which do most of the merger work
With Android instead of you.
I'm Ian Lick , and I 'll talk to MediaSessionCombat
, How you can start making Metadata your modes
Your controls are everywhere.
Think of MedaiSession as a general interface
To restart your media.
No matter whether you're playing, audio file, tape, or even remotely
Through Google Cast, if you do not tell the system what you are doing,
It can not help you.
It gives you many ways to help you,
By posting metadata such as photo album or artist name
And tell him what controls the mediator
Such as playback and stop-backs.
But I speak quickly.
Let's create a MediaSessionCombat component to get started.
Unfortunately, the versions of Android pre- Lollipop
This would require a preliminary step,
By creating what we call the receiver of the intermediate button.
Which captures media controls
From things like Bluetooth headsets and Android devices,
And connect it to your application on devices smaller than Android 5.0.
It is a simple transmission future,
In your file,
And translate the important event you reach
To actions in your app.
In general, delegated operating and suspension controls
To the service they control
In the background of running your broker.
See our training documents for example.
Well, finally, MediaSessionCombat
You will need a context: any string to serve as a debug tag
And the component name for the future of your broker button.
The last null is Intent .
You can use it instead of the component name in Android 4.3.
It is created for us if we pass null
It is often the right thing to do.
You may want to do these three things
Before you go further.
Place the appropriate flags to say that we already have media controls buttons
And we want to send it to our application.
Next, we want to put resend.
Here is where Lollipop reaches the top devices
Re-connect with playback, stop and others
When the button is pressed.
Finally, place the session on playback mode
When you are ready to run something.
This is the directory to the system to direct the middleman buttons
And other controls to your app.
Well, the setting is running and ready,
But we do not let the butterflies sink us
About playing our media.
How does he know what he is supposed to occupy, and what controls do we support?
MediaMetadatCompat costs the first part.
It uses a build style, where you only have to
To add all the information you have,
Then call setMetadata () in the MediaSession
But media controls are still absent.
Because we did not do the other part,
It is a PlaybackStateCompat deployment
For PlaybackStateCompat two goals,
Immediate status: such as turning on or off
Or download, via setState ()
And immediate actions such as stop or stop,
SetActions ()
They contain them together, because often things change
At the same time with the case.
Suspension is often not available on the arrest act,
for example.
This is enough to make MediaSync Combat work.
You will find integrated media and Bluetooth buttons in all API devices
Top hardware, and screen close controls
In Ice Cream Sandwich, Jelly Bean and Kitkat.
You will also find MediaSessionCompat
Works well with NotificationCompat.MediaStyle
Part of the AppCompat Support Library
Which will give you very beautiful media notifications
At all API levels, including even the built-in media controls on the API
On devices 14 and above.
Just remember to call SetMediaSession
With code for special and unique media session
Of your media course.
This brings your media session to "Android wear"
And gives you controls for media in Android 5.0
And above.
Do not forget to release it when you finish
Fully cycle your media.
Honestly, Latensua.
We just talked about the basics of MediaSessionCombat
We did not talk about media browsers
Media controls, and many things
Based on the media cycle.
But this will enable you to start, and make the information run
Media, and operating controls are available
Wherever he was.
I look forward to seeing your wonderful media
Using MediaCentCompat, I hope
They will help you build better applications.
And launch.